something came up and it just put a
confirmation on what you what you said
you removed the doubt that michael
jackson
indeed accepted islam yeah
i used to work in the uae and one of my
neighbors was the cameraman for jermaine
jackson
yeah so he would uh he would go and do
some documentaries for him in africa
so he was the right-hand man for
jermaine jackson which is michael
jackson's brother
who's a muslim of course and uh he
totally confirmed that he died as a
muslim
you said something about someone prayed
janaza on him yeah they prayed
like quite a few uh communities they
prayed as an absence
yeah okay so it's con it's confirmed
that he did die as
a muslim michael jackson did die as a
muslim yeah i mean his brother would
know him the best right that's the
closest person
jermaine jackson yeah jermaine's people
are like this is such an old topic why
are you guys bringing it
um yeah go ahead how did this come up
how did it come up actually i was
talking
i was talking to the two romanians and
then we got you involved
we were giving them some dawah and then
i think one of the romanians brought it
up because we were in indiana
yeah and they brought up my they brought
up michael jackson
yeah they said that this is the place
where mike jackson was born
and i said right away well he died as a
muslim yeah that's how it came out now
we confirmed
that he did die as a muslim towards his
last years yes
alhamdulillah